leading expert in sovereign debt and
sanctions jay newman jay very good
morning to you so i mean that's that's
really the nub of the issue here a ban
on russian gas is ultimately the biggest
stick that the eu can wield
um it is the biggest but you have to
take into account that the eu has
already paid uh putin 38 billion dollars
since he invaded ukraine so you wonder
whether they're going to have the guts
to actually do that it's going to be
very expensive
and also we hear this morning that uh
the ban eu's ban on russian coal is
actually going to take longer to
implement than expected as well because
uh germany is dragging its feet
and it's and if you think about it coal
is small beer it's about it's symbolic
but it's about four billion dollars a
year nothing like what the gas and oil
are
so can you see the eu actually cutting
back on russian oil in particular the us
has done it the uk has done it is this
the next
move if you like for the eu
oil is is much more feasible than the
gas i think gas will take a lot longer
to replace but you could see them
cutting back on the oil but
the bigger point is that sanctions don't
really work for regime change
and the under money will keep flowing
this is the money not seen publicly that
influences people and events
and that oil will find a home it'll find
a home in india in china and elsewhere
it's just going to keep moving and money
will keep flowing to russia
so jay i mean you've used the term
regime change there i mean what are the
kind of things that the west has to do
short of military action to get putin
out
uh
it's it's hard it's hard to imagine
anything else uh and uh we're already at
an economic war
uh i doubt that we're gonna really move
into kinetic war although we're
supplying weapons so you could argue
that we're already at war with russia
um but i'm i'm very skeptical that in
the short term uh putin is going
anywhere
is it fair to say jay that the west has
kind of come up really now against the
limits of what it can do against russia
without severely hurting itself
and we're already hurting ourselves i
mean prices prices going up for
commodities uh agricultural commodities
are through the roof
uh critical elements like palladium and
neon are constrained uh it's and it's
all going to feed back into inflation
it's a it's a very very expensive
process to sanction a nation like russia
what have you made of the sanctions on
russian banks in particular last night i
mean i've seen it suggested that this is
really now approaching the level of u.s
sanctioning of iranian banks a few years
ago
the um the thing about sanctions is and
even sanctioning those banks is that
they've been preparing for this for many
years at least since uh 2014
so it is i i'll say it's more than
inconvenient it's it's uh but it's not
as dire as people would think
uh there are plenty of institutions and
plenty of people around the world that
want to help evade sanctions and that's
what's going on behind the scenes that's
the under money
so how do we get those people the people
who are enabling sanctions evasion
i i i think it's almost impossible uh
it's a huge industry and more people
keep coming out of the woodwork there
are lawyers there are bankers there are
trust officers i mean you see we see the
tip of the iceberg
with the uh with the yachts and the
planes
that's inconvenient but
oligarchs can still go to nice places uh
they can go to uh dubai they can go to
oman they can go to cuba venezuela uh
it's a different life but it's not a bad
life
and what sort of nationality are these
people these facilitators of sanctions
busters are they basically middle
eastern and venezuelan and cuban as you
suggest or are there westerners involved
as well in this activity well it's uh
you know famously wyoming is a place
where lots of shell companies are formed
so wyoming and nevada
delaware to some extent
uh the in the entities are all over the
place but historically the the home of
the most creative and sophisticated uh
money laundering hiding hiding and
burying has been london
i think many of those service providers
are now uh having to work in different
ways but
you know my belief is they're still in
business
so what can the london financial
regulators do to to curb this
uh what they're what they're doing they
can constrain it they can curb it but
they can't keep people from traveling
and they can't keep other
other places and other people from
popping up in different jurisdictions to
provide the same services it uh all
those become more expensive and more
complicated but the money is still
flowing think about the 38 billion that
the eu has paid just for gas and oil in
the last couple of months
that money's going somewhere and it's
going somewhere safe it's just flowing
underground we don't see it but you can
be sure that putin isn't selling oil and
gas and not getting money in a safe
place
jay just before i let you go
we've learned overnight that russia has
made its latest debt repayments on its
on its debt it's coupon payments and so
forth in rubles rather than us dollars
how long before russia formally defaults
do you think
uh russia is really making uh i look i
i've gotten this completely wrong i
thought russia would go into the grace
period at least they would have 30 days
to make the payments they didn't take
advantage of that so they're playing a
very interesting game and the other
thing i'd point out is that using rubles
and playing in the ruble markets is
their game and a lot of people are
making a lot of money
knowing what the central bank of russia
is going to do and knowing what the
russian policy toward instead is so
every every time we see a movement or a
decision on the debt or in the ruble
somebody is making money all right jay
it's been fascinating talking to you
this morning thanks very much indeed for
joining me at such an unsociable hour as
well
my pleasure